wait whose is it just me and Bob right
now is it a 1v1 it's a face-off
it's a [ __ ] face/off we got a
face-off we got a piss off hear the
crowd make room I got my sniffer ready
I'm gonna hung you down Bob
just like the oh well computer mouse are
you you know I did try and become the
computer mouse but turns out you are
wonder where you are stuff knock her
over good I got your number now it's
just this error for me you just carry
her it's a really long auto rifles like
the clip going into the top didn't check
to make sure you guys had all the games
and stuff done damned all of you being
like whoo check out the little make sure
you have no hesitation on that grenade I
didn't mean I should plant and I was
like no it needs to happen wait a minute
wait wait wait wait turn around wait
wait turn around you missed it it was
[Laughter]
there was a rogue bucket there's a rogue
bucket those bounces did you cut them
off I'm not crazy
there's a insane wait a minute we come
back
around yes wait come back it was here
definitely real way to worry I don't
believe in this bucket there was a
bucket I marry come on Wade jeez man I
don't know how you keep losing this
imagine there was a bucket and it was mu
by a bucket a bucket no no no let's talk
about this I'll show you where Jack is
wait that was my bucket kill no no I
found this bucket no I was running after
there's no you guys want to fight over
the kill I have an idea I'm gonna hop
over here okay and then you guys go out
there okay pal a shotgun
you didn't even believe in the bucket
okay I was gonna do Z's is your gun full
of poop good the [ __ ] blaster yes it's
the prophesize [ __ ] blaster and I ate a
lot of beans yesterday there's a little
suspiciously play stuff that I don't
remember being that way I'm using your
own stupidity against you know my one
weakness
I keep hearing shots in the distance but
I don't I haven't seen it understand why
this worked I don't understand how you
did this this isn't weakness me
stupidness is strength me brain are big
strong I'm less optimistic that this is
gonna work but if it does I mean there's
20 seconds left we'd combine our
brainpower we uh think our body so hard
right now
[Laughter]
I don't feel like I deserved that I
don't feel like you deserve it either
yeah you could have come and there's a
big missing I know that for factoid you
don't know that for a fact I'm pretty
sure if you do a count of all the bins
in the office you'll find that there are
exactly the number of bins that there
should be how many I don't know why
don't you answer hey douche bags where
are you you know around next to you in
front of you around you I've been a good
boy I've moved now are my sunshine my
only sunshine
you guys get to deserve to know what I
was cuz I was very in the opener were
you a bucket no no I wasn't I tried a
lot of things and I was like I'll do
this thing that no no no I was a plant
in the room where you shot every plant
except for me incredibly well for me
let's be very focused about this and pay
very close attention that smell and
smoke delicious that's just like smoked
smoked Shaq almonds smuggling you know
now my eyes hurt from all the
particulates from the smoke you guys
should be aware it's a non-smoking
office health code regulation state you
are [ __ ] just for smoking you're an
[ __ ]
yeah doesn't it seem like an appropriate
punishment in such a mark I noticed the
flipped over chair Oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
where were you in the name of the
seventh I think Marvel time right now
it's the night of the seventh I know oh
wait it's you it's like I knew you'd be
here on the day of my murder wait wait
did you break down this back window yes
okay you guys want to find us you better
handle with care wait there milk well
okay okay in fairness in fairness we are
smoke and or a smoke like object a pipe
no vape there vapes there hookah pipes
salmon smoked salmon hidden mean chimney
wait wait wreck I've got one that will
not help them at all okay okay what we
are we're kind of the same thing and I
trip us there a bishop was together yeah
ship just be fragile with our
relationship though yeah and you eat it
and you get smarter ship ship us box
smoke I get it fragile handle with care
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]